le noble défi que doit remplir
l'agriculture aujourd'hui c'est de
proposer de la nourriture pour tous et
en 2050 pour 9 milliards et demi d'êtres
humains aussi avec la crise économique
agricole nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
d'une agriculture très productive
créatrice d'emplois d'économies dans le
secteur agroalimentaire il faut être
réaliste et compétitif rivaliser avec la
concurrence mondiale des autres pays
industriels avec le changement
climatique l'eau devient rare les
bassines ou encore les innovations comme
les semences ogm constituent de réels
espoirs pour la sécurité alimentaire les
contraintes environnementales sont donc
des obstacles trop difficile à franchir
pour les exploitants agricoles français
on ne peut pas se permettre d'être
utopiste
stop stop stop vous avez tous entendu ce
message sur les ondes radio et ce
message n'est en vérité qu'une vaste
propagande mensongère
les premières victimes de ce modèle
agricole au delà des consommateurs
empoisonné par les substances toxiques
utilisés par l'agriculture sont les
agriculteurs eux-mêmes qui
économiquement ne s'en sortent pas
qu'ils sont malades maladie
professionnelle à cause de ces
pesticides et qui pour 500 d'entre eux
chaque année font le choix de se
suicider un car un quart des
exploitations agricoles ont disparu ces
dix dernières années le nombre de fermes
a été divisée par cinq depuis 1955
aujourd'hui on fait de l'agriculture
raisonnée et grâce au progrès on peut
nourrir l'humanité la planète
mais cette agriculture raisonnée ne
nourrit pas la planète
sept milliards d'êtres humains
aujourd'hui à la surface de la planète 1
milliard d'entre eux souffrent de la
faim 35 millions d'êtres humains meurent
de faim chaque année un enfant de moins
de 10 ans meurt de faim toutes les cinq
secondes des facultés de la terre les
facultés de la terre les facultés de la
terre avec un petit et celle que nous
les paysans tenant non à la faculté de
la terre avec un grand t celle qui nous
portent tous sont saccagées par ce
modèle agricole qui dévastent les
équilibres qui dévastent les ressources
et l'eau en particulier qui dévastent
les biodiversité qu'elles soient
sauvages ou domestiques et qui dévaste
le climat et notre santé n'importe quoi
mais qui êtes vous pour vous exaltée de
la sorte
enfin encore un de ces bobos écolos
marginal chevelu barbu soixante huitards
attardés ou un de ces citadins qui ne
connaissent vraiment rien à
l'agriculture et qui veut nous donner
des leçons sur nos exploitations
on n'a pas le droit de faire rêver les
gens je suis désolé tous les paysans ne
sont pas d agréer les agriculteurs ne
sont pas des paysans revanche tous les
paysans sont des agriculteurs et j'aime
à dire que je me refuse d'être un de ces
exploitants qui exploite la terre qui
exploite les hommes qui exploite les
animaux et sur des exploités sur une
exploitation agricole je suis fier de me
revendiquer paysans qui évoluent sur une
ferme
mais je suis désolé les ogm par exemple
elle clown à ce sont des belles avancées
oui j'ai aussi dans mon parcours dans
mon parcours scolaire qui m'a conduit un
diplôme d'ingénieur conduit des
programmes de recherches sur le clonage
sur les ogm qui sont des sujets qui ne
sont pas du tout polémique
j'ai aussi organiser la vente de
pesticides de semences de synthèse
d'engrais de synthèse aussi de de
semences certifiées d'irrigation de
drainage tout ça j'ai fait ces métiers
là sauf que je me suis vite rendu compte
que c'est logique là ne sont que des
fuites en avant qui servent l'intérêt
privé de quelques uns au détriment de
l'intérêt général
m'enfin ne soyez pas nostalgique et
rétrograde l'agriculture maintenant ce
sont des entreprises compétitives à
l'échelle mondiale et sur mon
exploitation je pratique l'agriculture
raisonnée on a fait des progrès mais
yeux parlez-moi de progrès ici à la
rochelle où un illustre mère qui
s'appelait michel crépeau en donner une
définition fort édifiante
il nous disait que le progrès n'était
qu'une tradition qui se prolonge
c'est quoi le progrès dont vous nous
parler c'est le traité transatlantique
taffetas qui nous promet de nous nourrir
avec des poulets javellisée ou des bains
du boeuf aux hormones qui va nous faire
apporter massivement du soja et du maïs
ogm qui va nous interdire de produire
des fromages au lait cru comme le
roquefort ou le camembert savate
agriculture raisonnée qui sous l'ère du
grenelle de l'environnement signée en
2008 devait nous faire diminuer de
moitié l'usagé des pesticides en
agriculture et qui depuis 2008 a permis
d'augmenter tous les ans un peu plus
l'usagé de pesticides dans l'agriculture
qui fait que la france reste le
troisième utilisateur mondial de
pesticides au monde après les états unis
et la ddt qui sont quand même des pays
un petit peu plus vaste que notre petit
pays français et qui fait surtout de la
france le premier utilisateur en doses
par actares de pesticides au monde
est ce que vous voulez qu'on reste aussi
les champions du monde des cancers pour
nos enfants
en ça ce n'est pas prouvée
c'est justement parce que c'est prouvé
que j'ai quitté ce monde là que j'ai
fait le choix de partir et de et de
m'engager dans ma vie professionnelle
dans ma vie personnelle dans l'intérêt
supérieur des générations futures et
j'ai l'habitude de dire que mon adage
c'est l'amour et le moteur et la colère
que vous sentez tout ce j'imagine
aujourd'hui et le carburant
écoutez l'environnement ça commence à
suffire
laissez nous produire rien de tout ça de
fait de vous un agriculteur capable de
conduire une exploitation agricole en
plus avec votre moteur on est des chefs
d'entreprise responsables mais j'y viens
j'y viens gg j'ai bâti un projet
d'installations agricoles sur une ferme
familiale qui elle est et qui était elle
est elle allée très loin dans le
développement de ce modèle intensif qui
pendant 35 ans a pratiqué la monoculture
de maïs et ses 20 années d'expérience
professionnelle avant de devenir
agricoles ont nourri mon projet et le
projet s'appuie sur deux principes
fondateurs
le premier principe il est territorial
on ne peut pas poser une activité
agricole comme on la pose au milieu de
nulle part
l'agriculture occupe 70 % de l'espace et
donc doit intégrer son environnement
social son environnement écologique et
son environnement économique et sur le
bassin versant de la seudre territoire
sur lequel j'évolue à l'estuaire duquel
se développe la l'emblématique activités
ostréicoles de l'huître de marennes
oléron on ne peut pas continuer de
développer des pratiques agricoles
désastreux sur la gestion qualitative et
quantitative de l'eau qui menace cette
florissante économie de 8 de
l'ostréiculture de marennes oléron qui
pourtant représente cinq fois plus
d'économies
cinq fois plus d'économies que la
maïsiculteurs la maïsiculture sur ce
même bassin et le second principe c'est
quoi le second principe c'est l'argent
public vous êtes tous contribuables
et bien sachez que l'agriculture est une
activité économique lourdement soutenu
par l'argent public et que aujourd'hui
quand on accepte de recevoir autant
d'argent public et j'en accepte je crois
qu'on a des comptes à rendre à la
société qu'on doit remplir un contrat
moral avec la société et donc dans ce
contexte là dans ce contexte là on ne
peut plus parler de contraintes
les agriculteurs n'ont que des noms que
des obligations
enfin l'agriculture a quand même un rôle
à jouer
changement climatique
oui effectivement le sujet et sans
tralala proche de cette coque 21 qui qui
s'annonce en france début décembre
effectivement l'agriculture un rôle à
jouer sur le changement climatique parce
qu'elle aimait elle même 25 à 30% des
gaz à effet de serre émis par les
activités humaines les vaches qui tu es
voilà les poncifs habituels les
éructations des bovins les vaches qui
pète et bien c'est pas ça le sujet le
sujet c'est par exemple la fertilisation
azotée savez vous qu'il faut 1,5 litre
de pétrole pour produire 1 kg d'azoté et
que l'agriculture dont on parle
utilisent massivement ses fertilisation
azotée c'est à dire que pour produire un
hectare de blé un hectare de colza ou un
hectare de maïs
l'agriculteur mobilise entre 200 et 270
kg d'azoté par ha ça veut dire qu'avant
même que le moteur détracteurs commence
à tourner rien que sur la fertilisation
azotée la dépendance au pétrole et de 3
à 400 litres par hectare
et ce modèle agricole qui en 2050
justement justement quand le pétrole se
fera extrêmement rare veut pourtant
nourrir 9 milliards et demi d'êtres
humains sur la base d'un modèle
excessivement dépendant du pétrole
c'est juste illusoire et puis le second
la seconde entrée quand on parle de
changement climatique en agriculture
c'est cette cette dimension que je vous
ai donné tout à l'heure l'agriculture
occupe 70 % de l'espace
et bien quand on occupe 70 % de l'espace
on doit mobiliser ces territoires pour
qu'il séquestre du carbone or ces sols
qui reçoivent massivement des engrais de
synthèse qui reçoivent massivement des
pesticides sont des sols sur lesquels on
a tué la vie hors des sols en faculté de
séquestrer du carbone ne peuvent être
que des sols en vie ce qui n'est plus le
cas avec le modèle agricole oui m'enfin
eux l'économie dans tout ça à la vôtre
agroécologie c'est bien beau c'est bien
joli mais enfin il faut amender rentable
oui ce modèle dominant n'est même pas
rentable j'en veux pour preuve les
manifestations d'agriculteurs régulière
qu'on avocats auxquels on a assisté il
ya quelques semaines encore
ce modèle est en train de toucher le
fond et donc il nous faut revisiter ce
modèle est le modèle que j'ai développé
sur la ferme familiale qui pourtant
était allé très loin dans le money
en cif qui était lourdement endettée
quand je les cantons la reprise avec
avec mon frère en choisissant d'autres
logiques basé sur l'autonomie basé sur
l'agronomie nous a permis d'apurer les
dettes nous a permis de bâtir un modèle
agricole rentable nous a permis d'être 9
hier il était que deux donc ce modèle
est également économiquement pertinent
on peut pas changer du jour au lendemain
tendez vos les vélos a pas de traitement
pas de traitement pas de récolte mon
père disait ça aussi que pas de
traitement pas de récolte sauf qu
effectivement il faut changer de
paradigme et et et redécouvrir dans ce
qu'on appelle le bon sens paysan la
faculté que peut avoir un bon paysan de
mobiliser des ressources parfaitement
gratuite est parfaitement inépuisable
que son l'azoté atmosphérique que sont
la lumière que sont la vie des sols que
sont le carbone et j'ai bien compris il
y en avait de plus en plus donc
effectivement on peut on peut redéfinir
un autre phase une autre façon de
produire et on est beaucoup plus
efficace dans ces logiques là en
produisant en associant les arbres vous
allez me parler des solutions j'imagine
alors les larmes par exemple à des
cultures danse dans un modèle qu'on
appelle agroforesterie j'ai planté cinq
mille arbres par an sur ma ferme depuis
huit ans pendant que le modèle le modèle
agricole dominant s'acharne à faire
disparaître ces arbres et bien en
associant les arbres avec les
productions végétales
on accroît la productivité hectares des
parcelles de 40% et dans les territoires
du sud là où les bouches attendent de la
nourriture
ce modèle agronomique basé sur l'arbre
permet d'augmenter la productivité des
terres de 400%
donc c'est tout sauf un modèle qui
affame messi mais
mais vous allez affamés la planète je
suis désolé il faut bien du maïs pour
produire sans chimie sans pesticides
mais vous êtes des irresponsables les
animaux d'élevage
écoutez moi bien la révolution c'est de
nourrir des herbivores avec de l'herbe
et et avec les animaux de races locales
on produire pour produire pour produire
des aliments de qualité que sur ma ferme
mon vent en vente directe à des tarifs
moins élevés que les produits
industriels que vous achetez que vous
acheter au supermarché comme les
herbivores mangent de l'herbe
les productions végétales sont toutes
dédiées à l'alimentation humaine et
voilà comment on allume véritablement
des cercles vertueux pour satisfaire les
la souveraineté alimentaire vous avez
peut-être me parler aussi des races
locales anciennes tout ce blabla
absolument les races locales en ciel
sont des garanties sont des garanties
sont des garanties de bonne adaptation
territoire idem pour les semences les
ces semences sont rustiques et nous
permettent sur le territoire de
développer des logiques productive qui
s'appuie sur le retour de l'autonomie
semencières et et et génétique
voilà vous êtes vraiment loin de la
réalité un tout le monde ne peut pas
s'offrir des de vos produits bios et du
lui sans fin c'est une niche quoi mais
ce qui plombe le pouvoir d'achat du
consommateur c'est pas le prix du
produit que vous achetez c'est les coûts
externalisée de ce modèle agricole qu'il
faut adossé à l'achat de ces produits et
qui font que par exemple les
contribuables que nous sommes tous
doivent s'acquitter d'une facture de 54
milliards d'euros par an 54 milliards
d'euros par an pour retirer les
pesticides et les nitrates de ce modèle
agricole qui en amont du geste de
production a déjà reçu 11 5 milliards
d'euros dette publique et qui nécessite
qu'on engage énormément d'argent public
pour réparer les dégâts de ce modèle
agricole da est ici et je prends souvent
souvent l'exemple de l'année tu pour
illustrer tout ça compte quand
effectivement vous arrivez sur le banc
du marché et que vous avez devant vous
une laitue à 70 centimes d'euros issus
de l'agriculture chimique et que à côté
vous avez une
les tubes issus de l'agriculture
biologique qui définitivement ne vous
coûtera 15 euros
et bien en réalité quand vous achetez
cette laitue à 70 centimes d'euro vous
la payez 27 euros et bien moi je dis moi
je dis que je n'ai pas les moyens de me
payer une laitue à 27 euros et est dans
cette situation
dans cette situation de crise où tous se
plaignent d'une pression fiscale trop
forte
exigeons exigeons que l'argent public
soit fléchi au bon endroit dès le début
et faire autre chose de l'impôt proposé
est captée sur le revenu des
contribuables
si en plus la société doit se mêler de
l'agriculture eh bien oui
ces constats font que font qu
effectivement ces constats font qu
effectivement la question agricole n'est
pas un sujet à cantonner dans un débat
agricolo agricole l'agriculture est un
vrai sujet de société duquel il faut que
tous s'empare de manière à engager les
alternatives
c'est pas facile hein c'est pas facile a
connu ça et donc et donc pour détendre
l'atmosphère et j'aime bien citer
coluche j'aime bien citer que lui ce qui
en 78 nous disait déjà que en attendant
peut-être que les choses à un mouvement
de fond se mette en place que finalement
tout ça nous appartient et tout ça
appartient à nos choix de consommation
et coluche nous disait en 78 il
suffirait qu'on ne l'achète pas pour que
ça ne se vendent plus et bien je vous
invite à réfléchir à faire
c'est pas fini ses papilles c'est patron
de seconde
alors c'est quoi le défi du siècle est
le défi du siècle vous l'avez compris le
défi du siècle c'est de réconcilier les
paysans et les consommateurs c'est de
réconcilier l'homme et la nature et se
défient la seule l'agriculture
biologique peut le relever
et cette crise est finalement une
opportunité pour s'emparer des
difficultés replacer la question
agricole dans un débat de société et
faire que des fermes citoyenne comme la
mienne des fermes paysannes comme la
mienne et d'autres font la démonstration
que ce modèle est possible et que ce
modèle est en marche je vous remercie
beaucoup de votre temps
quand on finit hélas